26 bureaux des assedic occupés par des
chômeurs à la veille d'une journée
d'action nationale gouvernement
embarrassé majorité divisée face à
l'abrogation de ce mouvement algérie
comment arrêter les massacres la
communauté internationale s'interroge de
gouvernement d'alger refuse toute
ingérence les premiers depuis mon film
et son terrifiant un tournant dans la
médecine des chercheurs américains
soigne les cardiaques grâce à la
thérapie génique plus de pontage mais
une ressource naturelle des artères
coronaires le premier side est alité de
france au muret près de toulouse plus de
livres et de cahiers tout et sur écran
est sous surveillance pour respecter la
liberté de chacun l'industrie française
de l'armement invente larmes total un
fusil avec caméra qui permet de viser
sans être vu à projectiles tirés au
millimètre près sur la cible
madame monsieur bonsoir de 18 bureaux
des assedic occupés par des chômeurs
hier soir on est passé à 26 ce soir sur
les 600 que compte la france
le mouvement prend donc une certaine
ampleur demain une marche de
protestation est prévue à paris et dans
plusieurs grandes villes du pays face à
cette fronde gouvernement et majorité
sont divisés embarrassé certains élus
socialistes sans attendre une réponse
globale du gouvernement ont décidé de
prendre des mesures d'urgence c'est le
cas aujourd'hui notamment à marseille où
le président du conseil général le
socialiste lucien weygand a décidé de
débloquer plusieurs millions de francs
jacques cardoze vincent descendre ce
soir certains des chômeurs qui occupent
les assedic ont de quoi être satisfaits
c'est leur première victoire depuis le
début du conflit quinze mille d'entre
ceux dont la situation est la plus grave
bénéficieront d'une prime exceptionnelle
de 2000 francs
une aide financée par le conseil général
qui a pour objectif le paiement des
factures edf
une initiative motivée par l'ampleur du
complot s'il s'était agi comme les
années précédentes unique barre d'une
manifestation pour la prime de noël
bon je l'aurais compris mais si vous
voulez je n'aurais peut-être pas
mobilisé les moyens que je fais vraiment
mobiliser l'effort coûtera 20 millions
de francs une somme puisée dans une
caisse spécialement prévus à cet effet
il n'y aura donc pas d'augmentation du
budget mais cette aide ne concerne
qu'une partie des chômeurs ceux qui sont
en fin de droits ou les rmistes tous
ceux qui dépendent pas de l'assedic
donc effectivement il peut pas faire
plus et ils considèrent à juste titre et
nous avec
que ceux qui n'ait pas d'incidences à
l'assedic de payer donc effectivement il
faut que demain la lune est dit prêt de
ses responsabilités rétablisse le foll
sociale et disent oui je vais prendre en
charge pour entre autres un peu noël
mais pour tout le reste
en prenant cette initiative lucien
weygand reconnaît s'être démarqué du
gouvernement la date de cette annonce
n'a sans doute pas été choisi au hasard
à la veille du conseil d'administration
de l'unedic
sans doute la dernière chance d'obtenir
gain de cause pour nombre de chemins je
disais à l'instant visiblement cette
fronde des chômeurs divise et embarrasse
gouvernement et majorité depuis ce matin
les réunions se sont succédé visite des
ministres concernés à l'hôtel matignon
pour y rencontrer lionel jospin et
réunion ce soir du bureau national du
parti socialiste françoise david
physique l'outil
rien à dire en tout cas à la presse car
toute la journée comme ce matin à
matignon en compagnie de dominique
strauss kahn martine aubry a parlé parlé
d'emplois des 35 heures différentes eu
lieu dans l'après midi
nouveau rendez vous devant le couple
divers de la majorité plurielle radicaux
mouvement des citoyens vers embrassades
et voeux de bonne année
n'empêche pas une discussion serrée sur
les 35 heures bien sûr mais aussi leurs
créations sur l'axé mouvement des
chômeurs car dans la majorité les verts
et les communistes réaffirme haut et
fort leur soutien aux sans emploi qu'on
ne peut pas rester à une situation où un
ministre du travail dit que les
occupations sont illégales je crois
qu'il faut montrer que ce gouvernement
de gauche c'est un gouvernement de
gauche comprend la désespérance des
exclus et l'inquiétude des chômeurs et
que l'on ne peut plus se contenter de
dire que le chômage c'est quelque chose
de conjoncturelle alors qu'on sait qu'il
est structurel il faut entendre ce cri
qui monte des profondeurs de notre pays
de la part de ceux qui sont privés
d'emploi
ça suffit distille entendons le dans la
soirée au siège du parti socialiste
réunion du bureau national
là encore on évoque les occupations
d'assedic n'est pas fondé à discuter la
légitimité du mouvement
sa mère non faut lui trouver une
solution certains élus socialistes sont
allés sur le terrain rencontrer des
survivants luttent la direction du parti
socialiste exprime donc sa solidarité à
l'égard des exclus tout en soutenant le
gouvernement nous disons au gouvernement
nous voulons travailler avec le
gouvernement très vite au renforcement
des dispositifs d'insertion pour les
chômeurs de longue durée c'est pour nous
une une question urgente jeudi lionel
jospin a réuni l'ensemble de ses
ministres une réunion ii sort des
chômeurs devrait être longuement évoqué
majorité divisée donc gouvernement
embarrassé pour le moment que peut faire
que va faire lionel jospin jean michel
karp écoutez c'est vrai que depuis une
semaine ça tangue dans la majorité
d'abord dominique voynet puis robert hue
ont pris fait et cause pour les chômeurs
au point que matignon a décidé de ne pas
laisser traîner les choses
hier lionel jospin a téléphoné à
dominique voynet pour lui demander de
revenir sur ses propos
ce qu'elle a en partie fait aujourd'hui
et il doit voir robert hue dans les
jours qui viennent mais surtout selon
nos informations serait telle étude le
versement à terme d'une très importante
somme d'argent parle d'environ deux
milliards de francs susceptibles de
répondre pour une bonne part à la
situation d'urgence que connaissent
nombre de chômeurs notamment feu de
longue durée et en fin de droits mais en
fait on s'est beaucoup interrogé
également depuis le début de cette
semaine sur le fait de savoir à quoi
correspond exactement ce mouvement
initial la réalité c'est que les
chômeurs en lutte sont très peu nombreux
c'est vrai qu'ils sont encadrés par des
trotskistes de la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire et des militants cgt ou
communiste d'ailleurs souvent hostiles à
robert hue et qui en profitent pour
faire pression sur le gouvernement de
gauche
mais au-delà de tout cela ce mouvement
correspond à une réalité celle de la
misère dans laquelle vit beaucoup de nos
concitoyens qui n'en peuvent plus des
gens déjà exclu tu aimerais bien en plus
ne pas être oublié au moment où le
gouvernement parle d'un retour à la
croissance d'une amélioration de
l'emploi avec les 35 heures les emplois
jeunes puisqu'ils n'ont pas de travail
ils demandent au moins qu'on les aide à
tenir dans la vie ce qui déclenche un
mouvement de sympathie dans l'opinion
alors le pouvoir croyez avoir du temps
pour améliorer l'emploi mais c'est le
chômage qui le rattrape plus vite que
prévu d'où l'étude de mesures
financières importantes qu'il s'agit
d'un sacré défi pour lunel jospin à
noter encore qu après limoux dans l'aude
hier les bureaux des assedic de
perpignan et sur les images que vous
allez voir de clermont ferrand ont été
évacués par la police aujourd'hui à
clermont les policiers ont traîné dehors
une dizaine de personnes qui se
trouvaient à l'intérieur du local avant
de prendre position à l'extérieur les
chômeurs se retrouve en eux mêmes sur le
trottoir au départ il s'agissait d'un
phénomène marginal mais la situation
économique se dégrade dans le
développement des réseaux d'entraidé des
changes forme moderne du troc a amené la
justice à une première condamnation
aujourd'hui 2000 francs d'amendé avec
sursis pour trois personnes sur pleins
d'un artisan qui considérait qu'il
s'agissait là d'une forme de concurrence
abusive le tribunal de foix dans
l'ariège a donc tranché en sa faveur
ces réseaux regroupent il faut le savoir
aujourd'hui environ trente mille
adhérents qui ont donc abandonné
l'argent liquide comme forme de paiement
christophe la rocca olivier combe 2000
francs d'amendé avec sursis et le
versement d'un francs de dommages et
intérêts aux parties civiles
la peine prononcée par le tribunal
correctionnel de foix à l'encontre des
trois membres du réseau d'entre aide
n'est pas lourde elle est avant tout
symbolique
par ce jugement le tribunal a estimé
sarah tous coupables d'avoir eu recours
au travail clandestin pour réparer ce
toit le sien qui menaçait de s'effondrer
cette jeune anglaise sans ressources
régulières avaient fait appel à deux
amis dans le cadre d'une association des
changes de service elle a accueilli le
jugement avec dépit oui je vais laisser
la maison dans mes ans réunit green
probablement voilà au moins j'ai des
amis maintenant et c'est tout ce qui
compte
la france est le seul pays dans le monde
qui a qui a amené au tribunal qui a
condamné des gens pour une entraide qu'
il n'y a aucun celle du monde qu'il ya
plusieurs sel dans tous les pays du
monde y en a aucun qui a été amené un
tribunal et qui a été jugée
défavorablement les selles pour systèmes
d'échangés locaux
ce sont ces réseaux d'entraidé qui ont
fleuri un peu partout la pauvreté s'est
installée on peut s'y procurer des
produits souvent de première nécessité
en échange de petits services pour
s'assurer que les échanges sont
équilibrés on utilise une unité de
compte immatériel ici le grain de sel
l'avantagent pouvoir se procurer des
biens et des services que l'on ne peut
pas s'offrir au chômage ou rmi
inconvénient pour l'état et le système
économique traditionnel aucune taxe
n'est perçue sur ces échanges c'est pas
au moment où les voitures flambent dans
les banlieues ou les chômeurs occupent
les assedic qu'on peut en vouloir à des
gens qui essayent de faire correctement
leur métier d'homme
leur métier d'homme pour les adhérents
du sel c'est être solidaire aujourd'hui
sarah robert et john envisage de faire
appel
ce nouveau jugement fera jurisprudence
pour les 250 réseau d'entraidé de france
et la vie quotidienne des trente mille
personnes qui participent le président
de la république a commencé sa série de
voeux protocolaire ce matin devant les
assemblées il mettait en garde le
gouvernement contre un usage excessif de
la procédure d'urgence pour l'adoption
de textes de loi et cet après midi
devant les corps constitués il a une
nouvelle fois mis en garde contre
l'expansionnisme de l'état dans tous les
domaines jacques chirac
si l'état aujourd'hui dépérit ce n'est
pas par son retrait sysmans mais ça
compte mais au contraire par son
expansion continue c'est au moment où le
secteur public a atteint des dimensions
inégales et malgré les efforts qui ont
pu être faits pour le réduire au moment
où il emploie un actif sur quatre dans
notre pays que l'état est en réalité le
moins efficace une vaste réflexion a été
engagée au cours des dernières années
sous l'impulsion des gouvernements
successifs
elle a conduit à des initiatives
concrètes qui vont dans le bon sens il
serait très dommageable pour notre pays
que la portée de ces initiatives soient
restreintes ou que leur mise en oeuvre
soit différé le mauvais temps ils
s'éloignent de la france il était temps
car les flottes de pêche de bretagne 400
bateaux n'étaient pas sorties en mer
depuis une dizaine de jours maintenant
les dernières liaisons avec les îles
bretonnes ont reprises aujourd'hui la
dernière être remises en service étant
la navette entre belle-ile et le
continent reportage olivier sioux et
gabriel camilla la houle les vagues
légumes encore et toujours le long de la
côte sauvage à belle-ile
la tempête qui quatre jours durant a
secoué la bretagne pousse son dernier
souffle
mais de l'autre côté sur le port de
palais c'est tout bélisle qui respire
pour les 1500 vacanciers bloqués depuis
samedi la fin d'un suspense ce qui
apparemment n'avait rien d'un cauchemar
à part peut-être pour les finances le
carnet de chèques commençant à s'épuiser
un petit peu il est réduit à sa plus
simple expression il reste un chèque
dans chéquier c'est tout
il est temps que ça s'arrête or il est
temps que ça s'arrête oui mais d'un
autre côté on a vu un spectacle
inoubliable
enfin le bateau de quiberon harry
finalement on aura que deux jours de
retard au bureau cette semaine les
patrons qu'il a bien fallu prévenir se
sont montrés généralement compréhensif
devant ses vacances forcées
enfin tout dépend du patron évidemment
on va rentrer en caserne villageois non
je sais pas encore on n'avait pas vu une
nation france assure cette version on
appelle ça c'est puni par la loi donc on
va éviter pendant qu'on trouve à rabat
c'est la surprise soir quand je rentre
et pourtant tout le monde ne sera pas du
premier voyage dans les cafés autour du
port certains ont encore de vente eu
quelques heures de patience derrière des
gens qui devaient repartir et vous
repartirez commun où chacun son tour
adieu b l'insee sur volontaire ou pas
ses vacances prolongées n'auront pas
fait que des malheureux
d'ailleurs regardez il suffit que le
soleil fasse une apparition pour qu'une
simple traversée de la baie prennent
tout d'un coup un air de croisière
coupures d'électricité en bretagne en
seine maritime la tempête et les pluies
diluviennes ont surtout provoqué une
pollution importante de l'eau potable
reportage mathieu chez jean-pierre
pasteur la normandie a les pieds dans
l'eau et les normands de l'eau impropre
à la consommation
en seine maritime qui dit fortes pluies
dit souvent contamination des nappes
souterraines part de la chine et du
liban à yvetot dans ce bar où l'eau
n'est pourtant pas la boisson phare on
connaît la chanson
chaque rôle que les grandes lui donc
j'ai pendant quelques jours d'où les
problèmes même écolo matériel puisque la
machine à café
la résistance est à exploser tout
simplement le maire d'yvetot qui porte à
la fois la casquette d'élu et celle de
médecin veut tordre le cou à ce
désagrément saisonniers nouvelle station
de titrage et réseau rénové le nom
investissements viennent d'être décidées
pour éviter à l'avenir de recourir au
système d
on se donne 48 heures si le jeudi de
l'eau est encore un port la consommation
on mettra pour le week-end à disposition
des habitants de l'eau potable forme de
bouteille sous forme de grands
récipients
au total 66 communes touchées 35000
personnes à qui il est conseillé
d'éviter de boire de l'eau du robinet
sous peine de quelques désagréments le
risque qu'il est il peut être qualifiée
de marginale mais il est quand même
important dans certains cas c'est un
risque essentiellement de peut-être dans
certains cas avoir une une diarrhée ou
des troubles intestinaux
c'est ça le risque majeur si la pluie
s'arrête
il faudra attendre une dizaine de jours
pour retrouver une eau pure est clair
comme de l'eau de roche que faire pour
arrêter les massacres en algérie la
communauté internationale s'interroge
mais pour l'instant elle n'a guère de
solutions concrètes le gouvernement
algérien considérant toute initiative du
genre comme une ingérence dans ses
affaires intérieures
la france rappelle le droit légitime de
la population algérienne à être protégé
sur place après coup l'horreur des
carnages apparaît chaque jour un peu
plus notre équipe revient ce soir avec
un document filmé dans la région de
relizane à 250 km à l'ouest d'alger là
où il y a une semaine très exactement
près de 400 personnes selon la presse
algérienne ont été sauvagement abattus
jérôme b c'est un peu tard que les
rescapés des massacres regroupés dans
leur chef lieu ont accepté de s'armer
jusqu'à présent ils pensaient que la
neutralité était leur meilleure défense
tous ont encore en tête
ce premier soir du ramadan il ya une
semaine quand la rupture du jeûne a
sombré dans le cauchemar
dans leurs regards hauteur de douleur
que de détermination jeunes les noirs a
vu deux barbus vêtus de noir ont tué ses
trois cousins âgés de 15 mois 3 ans et 4
ans j'ai peur dit il
j'ai peint bachir aussi a réussi à
échapper aux tueurs
il a passé toute la nuit caché après
avoir repoussé de la main un coup de
poignard
le lendemain lorsque je suis revenu j'ai
trouvé ma femme et mes trois enfants et
gorges devait tenir un cap mais si
c'était des vrais musulmans
il n'est gorges aurait pas d enfant
maintenant on a pris les armes pour les
pourchasser dans son village déserté
dooley de sannine bachir nous a montré
la maison de ses cousins ici la barbarie
est encore visible fatma zohra deux ans
a eu la tête fracassée contre ce mur
dans ce lit dormait fatma et zahia cinq
ans elles viennent d'être enterré parmi
beaucoup d'autres je suis armé depuis
longtemps contre ces assassins
je savais où il son jeu les filles vous
faire livrer pour tout ce qu'ils nous
ont fait subir alors même que le secteur
a été ratissé par les forces de sécurité
le week-end dernier un autre massacre
ensanglanté des villages de l'autre côté
de ces montagnes le vent tant d'horreurs
en france la communauté algérienne se
fait entendre aujourd'hui par la voix
d'un chef religieux le moufti marseille
reportage yasmina faber didier beaumont
alger ou à marseille c'est l'heure de la
prière de la fin d'après-midi la fin du
jeûne en cette période de ramadan un
ramadan marquée par les massacres
sanglants devant lesquelles la
communauté algérienne de marseille ne
sait plus comment réagir
alors elle exprime une fois encore son
indignation
ça c'était une contre l'humanité mais
milieu ne veut pas à la religion
musulmane seule personne qui ait fait ça
pour moi c'est pas musulman quelqu'un
qui fait ça c'est pas les musulmans et
l'islam n'a pas dit faut qu il y ait
pour faire sac pour protéger le peuple
algérien contre rire
la question que je me pose moitié ici en
france tel jeu
ma douleur le grand mufti de marseille
pourtant plus théologien que politicien
a décidé de lancer un appel au
gouvernement algérien pour fortifier
cette légitimité il doit assumer l'eau
il doit trouver les moyens on va jerry
même wire il va trouver les moyens pour
assurer la sécurité de tous les citoyens
et c'est une tâche sacrée
quant à une intervention de la france l'
éventualité reste évoqué avec prudence
le s'il faut absolument une intervention
non pas une ingérence mille
interventions pour essayer d'être à côté
du peuple algérien cela peut se passer à
travers un accord pour le moment la
communauté algérienne de marseille /
réfugie dans la prière
en espérant que leur islam prendra le
dessus sur le fanatisme qui qu de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée la
commission informatique et libertés
chargé en france de surveiller les
atteintes à la liberté individuelle des
systèmes informatiques récompensé
aujourd'hui les meilleures initiatives
dans ce domaine au tableau d'honneur
lycée de muret près de toulouse
entièrement informatisé s'est doté d'un
comité de surveillance qui regarde de
très près les dérives éventuelles du
système thibault de barbeyrac et
christophe vignal
taratata vrinat lui fabre a disparu le
papier et le crayon dans ce lycée
d'avant garde le professeur fait encore
l'appel mais la feuille de présence est
informatisé 300 ordinateurs pour 900
élèves des connexions à internet des
bornes télématique
bienvenue au cyber lycée charles de
gaulle à muret
plus de papier plus de crayon et plus de
monnaie élèves et professeurs possèdent
chacun une carte à puce avec laquelle
ils payent repas photocopies ou café un
porte monnaie électronique qui fait
aussi fonction de cartables j'ai un code
sur cette carte un code confidentiel qui
me permet de rentrer sur mon cartable
électronique au dessus se trouvent des
logiciels des fichiers qui me sont
personnelles
est ce qu'un professeur a le droit de
l'entrée dans le cartable électronique
de cette question le proviseur la pause
à la commission locale informatique et
libertés des élèves des professeurs des
personnels administratifs
leur but que le développement de
l'informatique au lycée ne se fasse pas
au détriment des libertés individuelles
de la discipline ou de la pédagogie
cartable
documents confidentiels
lettre à petit ami ou autre un cartable
cartable physique que vous avez
actuellement si on a des doutes et ça
nous est arrivé quelquefois élèves
présents ils écoutent étude vise donc à
terme sur atar et regarde ce qu'il ya là
je pense qu'on pourrait faire deux
parties dans ce cartable la première
partie ficelles qui serait personnel et
où chaque élève pour mettre ce qu'il
veut et où le professeur ne seraient pas
tenus d'y accéder et notre parti où ce
serait pour travailler notamment avec
des devoirs en classe des dossiers et où
le prof aurez droit de regard pour aider
l'élève je crois que là il ya aussi un
problème de confiance à jouer on vous
donne l'outil donne une possibilité à
charge pour vous de respecter et de
respecter les consignes quoi parmi les
précédentes décisions de la commission
la suppression des horloges
d'électronique impossible aussi de
savoir à quelle heure les élèves sont
passés à la cafétéria ou sur un
ordinateur
le système n'est donc pas un mouchard
mais reste pour les élèves un outil de
travail ultra perfectionné qui s'est
passé pour faure vous ne l'avez pas ça
me ferait parce que tout simplement vous
allez cette expérience est unique dans
l'éducation nationale mais c'est une
réussite comme en témoigne le prix que
la commission nationale informatique et
libertés décerne ce soir au lycée
charles de gaulle
le ministre des transports jean claude
gayssot a décidé d'offrir un billet de
rer gratuit à chaque spectateur du match
d'inauguration du stade de france qui
aura lieu le 28 janvier prochain
derrière cette générosité se cache
également un souci lors du premier match
officiel à saint denis qui avait réuni
seulement 8000 personnes un
embouteillage très sérieux avait
paralysé les abords du stade qui ne
possède que six mille emplacements de
parking pour 80000 places de spectateurs
rappelons tout de même que le choix
délibéré d'installer un stade en ville
impliquait que l'automobile n'était pas
le meilleur moyen d'y accéder philippe
visseyrias alban micro 6
voilà un vrai casse tête comment
acheminer relativement rapidement 80000
personnes ici au stade de france ce soir
exceptionnellement la voiture est une
bonne solution 25 minutes depuis le
centre de paris quoique arrivé sur place
il faut se garer et la compter sur la
chance ou arriver tôt il n'y a que six
mille places de parking deux raisons la
première c'est que on voulait jouer la
qualité de la desserte en transports en
commun
c'était le choix des autorités que
auquel nous avons souscrit la deuxième
c'est que réaliser des parkings est
horriblement coûteux et qui aurait payé
le contribuable une gare rer spécifique
sera opérationnel dans quinze jours elle
est situé à 10 minutes à pied du stade
que dessert aussi le métro parisien
inciter les spectateurs à délaisser la
voiture est une obligation
les abords du stade sont encore en
chantier comme ici le parking des
autobus
les travaux ont pris du retard c'est
ennuyeux mais pas irrattrapable
en revanche en cas de grands
embouteillages venir en voiture si
risqué de n'arriver qu'à la mi-temps le
match france-espagne du 28 janvier
prochain servira donc de test grandeur
nature et pas seulement pour les joueurs
de l'équipe de france
c'est sans doute le début d'une nouvelle
ère de la médecine la thérapie génique
en action une équipe américaine a réussi
dans une première expérience prometteuse
à traiter un malade du coeur en
réussissant à faire repousser les
artères coronariennes qui apporte le
sens au coeur jusqu'à présent les seules
techniques existantes étaient les
pontages jean daniel flaysakier bernard
puis ce sera un équipement lourd des
chirurgiens des anesthésistes très
expérimentée il faut tout cela pour
remplacer les quelques centimètres d'une
artère du coeur quand l'artère coronaire
est obstruée par une plaque de
cholestérol on va en effet faire ce que
l'on appelle un pontage en branchant
directement sur l'aorte une veine qui va
amener le sens aux muscles du coeur
au delà de la zone obstrué
les viardot pour réparer ses artères
bouchées
on aura peut-être plus besoin
systématiquement sur d'opérer à coeur
ouvert une équipe américaine vient en
effet pour la première fois de faire ce
qu'on appelle un essai de thérapie
génique
le principe faire déposer par un virus
un jeune dans la paroi des artères se
gênent va commander la fabrication de
nouveaux vaisseaux un pontage naturel en
quelque sorte
il est tout premier essai qui aurait été
effectuée chez l'animal ont montré qu'il
y avait eu une amélioration de la
qualité du tissu cardiaque après la
formation ces nouveaux vaisseaux pour
autant le comptage traditionnel ne
disparaîtra pas on travaille même
actuellement à des techniques de
thérapie génique pour empêcher les
veines greffés de se boucher alors que
l'un des chefs de file du mouvement anti
avortement le docteur xavier dor a été
condamné à 60 mille francs d'amendé
aujourd'hui le procureur de versailles
avait réclamé huit mois de prison ferme
le parquet pourrait faire appel de ce
jugement de cet après midi les douanes
françaises révèle aujourd'hui une
importante prise d'amphétamines effectué
au mois de décembre dernier à l'entrée
dû tunnel sous la manche côté français
52 kg pour une valeur de 4 millions de
francs la cargaison était dissimulée
dans le réservoir d'essence d'une
voiture conduite par un citoyen
hollandais
c'est la deuxième plus grosse prise des
douanes françaises dans ce domaine c'est
j'en fais ta mine était sans doute
destinée à fabriquer et des cachets
d'ecstasy direction la grande bretagne
le procès de maurice papon témoignages
émouvants cet après midi d'un rescapé
des camps de la mort qui avait fait
partie d'un des convois justement en
provenance de bordeaux dominique
verdeilhan sur place nous ne sommes pas
les survivants nous sommes des revenants
l'éosine guen est un des rares rescapées
de la mort dans mon convoi dit il nous
sommes partis à 1028 23 seulement sont
revenus il avait 15 ans quand il a été
arrêté à mont-de-marsan puis interné au
camp de mérignac
il se souvient de la brutalité de la
grossièreté des gars de français puis ce
fut la gare de bordeaux dans le
compartiment raconté 11 singles un
policier nous a demandé nautique et de
ravitaillement
là où vous allez vous n'aurez plus
besoin nous at il dit après drancy ce
fut les baraques en bois de pithiviers
puis le départ pour l'allemagne
c'étaient les trains de la mort dit il
leon sigal a fait plusieurs camps de
travail
il n'a rien oublié le froid des plaines
de silésie le jouerons la tatouée à
l'avant bras gauche
les violences les suicides les
pendaisons les cheveux tondus une
atteinte insupportable à notre dignité
dit-il nous vivions chaque minute avec
la mort nous étions obligé d'enterrer
nous mêmes nos camarades nous étions des
squelettes la vision était apocalyptique
mais jusqu'au bout poursuit l'ong égal
nous avons su rester des oeuvres à la
41e audience les jurés sont donc plongé
dans l'horreur des camps fini l'examen
des pièces administratives fini la
froideur et la raideur des arrêtés
préfectoraux et les on dit l'un d'eux
finit sa longue déposition par ces mots
depuis 1945 je me suis toujours retrouvé
du côté des opprimés
alors que j'ai l'impression que maurice
papon a continué à être du côté des
oppresseurs l'attitude de la suisse
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale une
nouvelle fois mise en cause par un
document d'une chaîne de télévision
britanniques dans ce film des réfugiés
juifs affirment qu'ils ont été mal
traités comme des esclaves à leur
arrivée dans la confédération helvétique
ils font même la comparaison avec les
camps de concentration londres etienne
leenhardt
après les accusations concernant lors
des nazis voici donc la suisse soumise à
un nouveau et douloureux face à face
avec son histoire à partir de
témoignages et des archives
la très sérieuse chaîne de télévision
channel fort affirme en effet qu environ
6000 juifs ont été internés dans de
véritables quand tu travailles sur le
territoire suisse pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale
on nous faisait dormir non pas sur des
matelas mais sur de la paille posés à
même le plancher
exactement comme dans les camps de
concentration nazis
quand j'étais interne et dans la prison
de neuchâtel avec d'autres réfugiés
on ne menaçait toujours de nous renvoyer
à la frontière allemande
la suisse est la police helvétique est
également accusé d'avoir elle-même
demandé à l'allemagne d'inscrire sur les
passeports de ses citoyens juifs la
lettre j ce qui lui aurait permis de les
identifier plus facilement au cas où il
traverserait la frontière si nous
voulons rétablir l'honneur national du
pays
il faut chercher la vérité nous devrons
affronter le passé avec honnêteté
si nous voulons un avenir honorable à
berne la capitale fédérale le
gouvernement suisse affiche son
étonnement et dénonce l' amalgame qui
est fait entre les camps d'internement
pour réfugiés et les camps de
concentration bien sûr c'est qu'on
n'était pas des camps de vacances
à l'époque les règlements étaient
certainement sévère mais ces gens là par
exemple pouvait étudier pouvait faire
des études avaient le droit de sortir
dans des intervalles réguliers de ces
quand ils avaient le droit de
correspondre on ne peut pas comparer ces
camps qui était en suisse avec des camps
par exemple dans les territoires et pays
occupé pendant la deuxième guerre sont
éteints des camps de concentration ni
des camps de travail forcé au nom des
survivants toutefois plusieurs avocats
américain s'apprêterait à porter plainte
contre le gouvernement suisse l'arrivée
massive de réfugiés kurdes sur les côtes
italiennes depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant a pour première conséquence
une réunion de tous les pâtes ou les
patrons des polices européennes ce sera
jeudi prochain en italie l'italie c'est
le port de débarquement des kurdes a
cheminé jusqu'à la côte est ensuite
livrés à eux mêmes les équipages
quittant les navires qui organise ces
passages les mafias qu'elle soit turc
albanaise 8 aliens philippe rochot
jacques girard reportage ce sont ces
bateaux de la guardia des finances à la
police des frontières qui sont chargés
d'intercepter les navires transportant
les réfugiés
mais aujourd'hui il cherche surtout à
arrêter les passeurs qui organise ce
vaste trafic sur 200km de la région de
il dispose de six navires ultra rapide
j'ai vu des fêtes à 21 ans ne fait pas
vraiment identifier les passeurs pour
l'instant mais nous savons qu'il y à des
albanais les turcs des grecs à
différents niveaux qui organise ses
voyages en organisant le cea jean en
faisant la chasse aux passeurs et aux
réfugiés kurdes la police des frontières
est tombé sur un vaste trafic de drogue
organisé par des albanais qui s'occupe
aussi de faire transiter les kurdes vers
l'italie nous ne commençons à contrôler
les kurdes que quand ils ont débarqué
dit le capitaine papa pour qui il est
difficile d'identifier les passeurs qui
souvent se cache parmi eux au camp de
sang de focale est réfugié kurde affirme
que pour venir ici ils ont dû contacter
plusieurs mafia ces gens qui avaient
débarqué du navire la comète le 1er
janvier montre même du doigt un certain
koumaye un capitaine turc qu'ils
accusent d'être de mèche avec le pouvoir
à ankara de l'irak à l'italie j'ai déjà
dû payer 3000 $ après il a fallu payer
la mafia albanaise qui nous a dévalisé
en nous menaçant avec des mitraillettes
ils nous ont pris notre argent nos
bijoux et c'est arrivé trois fois avant
qu'on débarque enfin ici à nice à ernée
coup derrière nous en attendant une
décision sur leur sort les kurdes
gardent en tout cas patience
la rencontre des polices de cinq pays de
l'espace schengen devrait aider à
trouver une position commune sur le
problème de ces réfugiés kurdes mais
l'italie a déjà fait savoir qu'elle
examinera au cas par cas
l'accueil de ces réfugiés et qu'il n'y
aura pas d'accueil globale pour tous les
gens qui arrivent qui si l'industrie
française de l'armement vient d'inventer
larmes total qui équipera l'armée
française du troisième millénaire il
s'agit d'un fusil qui a priori ne peut
pas manquer son objectif grâce à une
caméra
en effet le tireur est abrité de sa
cible qu'il peut repérer au millimètre
près on peut être par principe contre ce
type d' inventions il n'en reste pas
moins qu'il s'agit là d'une véritable
innovation à la pointe de toutes les
techniques dans ce domaine reportage
laurent boussier bernard ont fait 7 kg
de matière brute et d'intelligence la
puissance de feu d'un petit char
d'assaut et des formes futuristes pas
pop puisque c'est son nom de code
ressemble plus à une arme sorti d'un
film de science-fiction qu'à un fusil
d'assaut classique type famas et
pourtant d'ici une dizaine d'années
cette arme devrait équiper une partie
des fantassins france est une arme
redoutable à la fois fusil d'assaut
tirant des munitions de 5,56 et lens
obus de 30 mm elle présente des
caractéristiques jusqu'à l'heure
inconnues sur un champ de bataille c'est
une arme qui va permettre d'aller
chercher une cible même si elle se croit
à l'abri derrière un obstacle derrière
un abri derrière un arbre dans une pièce
même si on ne voit pas fusil à tirer
dans les coins
pas vraiment grâce à une caméra
thermique et à un télémètre laser placé
sous larmes grâce à un système de
conduite de tir
l'obus ou la grenade tirée par le soldat
suivra une trajectoire imposé par
l'ordinateur et explosera à l'instant
demandé un système redoutable qui permet
d'atteindre des ennemis même bien
protégés même derrière un mur ou un abri
autre innovation le soldat pourra
effectuer sa mission sans s'exposer
directement la caméra intégrée dans son
arme et les écrans de visualisation sur
le fusil ou placés dans son casque lui
permettront une visée déportés à l'abri
d'un mur ou d'un arm pour l'instant pas
pop n'est qu'un projet mais les
spécifications demandées par l'otan où
l'état major des armées sont claires
mettre hors de combat de jour comme de
nuit des cibles invisible et protégé
augmenté de 200 à 600 m la zone
d'engagement des fantassins
neutralisaient des cibles mobiles et
coûter moins de 15000 francs
le bucolique maintenant cette fois ci
c'est officiel châlons sur marne et
rebaptisé châlons en champagne un nom
qu'elle portait déjà au moyen âge il
faut le savoir
toute l'équipe municipale était d'accord
pour ce changement qui est plus
valorisant à l'étranger notamment
mais un irréductible avait déposé un
recours qui a considérablement retardé
cette décision françoise vallée manuel
bec au bord de la marne une commune de
60000 habitants
chalon sur ma logique mais la ville en
avait marre d'être confondus avec chalon
sur saône elle a donc décidé de changer
de nom et de reprendre celui qu'elle
portait du moyen âge à la révolution
châlons-en-champagne c'est aussi une
façon de rappeler que chalon est en
champagne la préfecture régionale
on connaît mieux la champagne quand on
est à tokyo ou à new york que la marne
les chalonnais ne sont pas surpris on
leur avait déjà annoncé la nouvelle il
ya deux ans les panneaux d'entrée de la
ville avaient été changés de nombreux
commerçants des entreprises avaient déjà
adopté le nouveau mis que c'est bien
c'est bien c'est plus significatif que
challans sur la rue moi ça n'a pas de
problème ou les pas de problème aucun
problème nous fait ça nous dérange pas
c'est un peu plus long à écrire quand on
est vieux on tremble un peu avancé à la
télé là pour moi c'est plutôt mieux dans
le tourisme ça peut nous apporter
quelque chose de supplémentaire mais ce
n'est pas du tout l'avis de jean
chalonnais depuis 40 ans ils avaient
déposé un recours devant le conseil
d'état
du coup pendant sept mois la ville était
redevenu châlons-sur-marne le premier
rezaï celui qu'il vient sur la publicité
du champagne ou sont les gilles provost
lui et il n'y a pas de vignes mais des
négociants plutôt satisfait de pouvoir
profiter d'un nom plus prestigieux alors
champagne pour chalon au passage la
petite sirène symbole national du
danemark installés le long des quais de
copenhague a été décapité par des
vandales ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'elle subit des avatars elle avait
déjà été peinturluré est l'un de ces
brassier même une fois sa tête déjà
coupé le rallye paris dakar aujourd'hui
c'était la plus longue étape mille
kilomètres dans les sables du sud
marocain entre ouarzazate et smara la
frontière mauritanienne
vainqueur dans la catégorie voiture du
français fontenay sur mitsubishi
abandons 2 peer l'arctique qui avait
pourtant remporté trois fois la course
dans la catégorie motos victoire du
slovaque catherine ac sur ktm
reportage alexandre car seuls face au
désert immense pour les concurrents du
dakar une étape inoubliable peut être
pas la plus dure mais la plus longue une
étape marocaine 1031 km
entre ouarzazate ismar à 1031 km face au
sahara occidental
extrêmement rapide des lignes droites à
l'infini pour les machines comme pour
les hommes
un calvaire des machines à l'épreuve des
routes caillouteuses des routes
parsemées de trous aux effets
dévastateurs des hommes face à la
poussière à la fatigue a semé par une
chaleur lourde il étape dure même pour
les meilleurs
pour pierre lartigue la course est finie
lartigue le français déjà triple
vainqueur de l'épreuve abandonne cette
fois c'était trop dur aujourd'hui sur la
piste il y a eu des boss de la casse
mais aussi des pleurs côté résultats on
retiendra de cette étape le retour dans
la course du motard stéphane peterhansel
hier le français s'était perdu
aujourd'hui et 2e de l'étape derrière le
slovaque catherine ac dans la catégorie
autos c'est aussi un français qui s'est
distingué jean-pierre fontenay deuxième
l'an passé du dakar a remporté sa
première victoire d'étape
demain cap sur de nouveaux paysages le
dakar dit le maroc pour la mauritanie
614 km de pistes direction soir
si les masses sortie demain du film la
prisonnière espagnole un film policier
où comme souvent le héros est pris dans
un engrenage infernal son réalisateur
david mamet nous présente son oeuvre où
le suspense mêlent souvent à l'absurde
aubry adler christian hottin on peut pas
se méfier de toujours et voilà comment
ça marche ça terrible aventure d'un
pigeon jo c'est son nom est un garçon
bien élevé brillant assez intelligent en
tout cas pour avoir mis au point un
procédé mystérieux qui fera la fortune
de ces requins de patron joe et naïf
mais ne veut pas se faire gruger
je suis vraiment c'est à voir et
forcément parce qu'apres ans messier
d'ennemis potentiels jo fini par se
confier des escrocs éventuels
commentaires la différence john n'a pas
l'air doux et le spectateur ne vaut pas
mieux je voudrais parler à la jambe
adjoint guillaume s'il vous plaît
j'ai toujours été fasciné par les
thrillers pour moi ce sont des contes de
fées pour adultes
on y trouve des gens ordinaires qui se
retrouvent plongés dans un monde qu'ils
nous comprennent pas un peu comme la
princesse qui s'enfonce dans une forêt
de plus en plus dans cet univers de faux
semblants où les faux flics sont aussi
convaincant que les faux amis
notre héros sombre lentement dans un jeu
effrayant de miroirs déformants
l'histoire est truffé d'amour en toc de
poursuites en vrac et de couzan vaches
il ya au moins un point sur lequel tout
le monde se retrouve la cupidité
l'argent n'est pas tout c'est ce que mon
patron du témoin c'est vrai il ya un bon
principe que mon père m'a inculqué en
affaires il faut se dire que la personne
avec qui on fait des affaires
essai de bousses escroqué parce que
c'est presque toujours vrai et si ça ne
l'est pas la surprise n'en sera que
meilleur il semble bien que la vraie
religion des états unis soit le business
si cela est vrai comme je le pense alors
tous les américains sont élus dans ce
culte dans cette histoire de faussaires
le crime est parfait davantage que le
film sans doute
il permet en tout cas de rappeler une
règle de morale élémentaire apprenant à
toujours séparés l'habit et lemoine
on va nous quitter le rappel des
principaux titres de ce mardi d'abord la
fronde des chômeurs 26 bureaux des
assedic occupés par des chômeurs à la
veille d'une journée nationale d'action
le premier ministre prépare et une aide
d'urgence qui pourrait aller jusqu'à 2
milliards de francs et qui serait
annoncée demain algérie commente à
arrêter les massacres la communauté
internationale s'interroge mais le
gouvernement belge et refuse toute forme
d'ingérence dans ses affaires
intérieures
voilà dans un instant la météo sophie
davant 20h50 à ne pas manquer maman j'ai
raté l'avion demain dans les 4 vérités à
7h50
françoise laborde recevra roland dumas
présidente du conseil constitutionnel
ancien ministre des affaires étrangères
de françois mitterrand
voilà je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne bonsoir album
tous